so I think that this movie's gonna come
out of left field for a lot of people
especially considering all the attention
that one woman has gotten this year the
timing is really great how much did you
know about the story of the origin of
Wonder Woman before you started the
project um I didn't I really didn't I
mean I I knew that she came from a comic
book and this comic book is almost 70
over 70 years old and what I didn't know
was that the man behind the creation of
this now very very famous female
superhero was a Harvard professor of
psychology who had earlier invented the
lie detector test with his very
intelligent wife Elizabeth Marston and
who then went on and had a polyamorous
relationship with with another woman and
they reared children together and lived
quite a beautiful existence but it's
extraordinary to think that that life
influenced the creation of Wonder Woman
so much so and what's lovely about the
film is it really shows you all the
signs throughout his life most of the
things that he put into the Wonder Woman
character was under his nose you know
yeah around the dinner table and evening
yeah just the experience he had with
these two women that he loved very
dearly this movie strikes really strikes
a good tone a nice balance between the
love that the three of them have for
each other the kind of danger of being
discovered and also all the kinky and
and the fetishes and that was like so
taboo for the time and people are still
uncomfortable with now how did you guys
strike that balance well you have to
remember the the the the the thought
process and the the person that William
Moulton Marston was he just he in
created this theory called the disk
theory which was dominance inducement
submission and compliance he wrote five
books on it in depth they're very
difficult to read if you're not an
academic like myself but what I do
understand is that those four categories
of emotion he finally found a medium in
which it was very clear how that was
represented and this was through you
know dominatrix and BDSM and all this
interesting stuff which they they
they tried it out you know they did as a
relationship closing a relationship they
tried those things he wanted to develop
it he wanted to understand and
experience what was it meant and how it
made you feel weirdly those then slowly
trickled into the the tools and the
weapons that Wonder Woman actually has
you know she has a golden lasso which
she tie somebody up with and he made
them tell the truth telling the truth
part is obviously influenced by the lie
detector test which he invented much
earlier on in his career so it's
fascinating that like the bracelets that
olive burn was always wearing and in his
photographs of her back in the day those
bracelets were part of the costume of
Wonder Woman that he immediately put on
and they deflect bullets you know so
there's a lot of incredible influences
which are touched upon quite nicely in
the film which if you're a fan and you
did see be that the movie of the summer
then it'll trigger some very fun moments
you to realize oh wow so that's where it
started you know and I think that's
great there's that great moment when
you're like yeah on Paradise Island it's
it's great and you work so closely with
your co-stars here it's very intimate
and again like like I had said earlier
they touch on these topics that were so
taboo at the time how comfortable will
you guys working together how did you
get to that point where you could be
comfortable shooting those scenes where
you guys are exploring all those all
those things just talked about you're
just well you have to do your work you
have to do your prep you have to
understand the why these people would
did what they did and who these people
were more influenced them and how much
love they had for each other and there
was a love respect and safety you know
they were they they experienced and
experimented with those things together
as a threesome and we we had a chemistry
from day one and we all knew where we
were gonna have to do those have those
moments and those experiences but it
never became awkward or uncomfortable I
think we just saw we all knew it was
part of the story and it needed to be
there for people to understand you know
these people really loved each other and
they were quite they were excited about
trying out these things you know and um
yeah I did we didn't bother Soto we
didn't talk about it I'm not she just
got on and did it I think I do it man
listen thank you so much for your time I
was truly really enjoyed the film's
thanks